اشعل مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بهدوءه خلال
معركه كلاميه مشتعله فيديو متداول يظهر
مساعده وزير الداخليه تركيا تناول الكعك
والشاي اثناء مشاده كلاميه بين وزير
الداخليه سليمان سويله والنائب اخر حول
ميزانيه الوزاره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اثر مقطع فيديو تم تصويره في حظيره اغنام
من شمال الصين الدهشه لدى المشاهدين بعد
ان انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وحير العلماء الذين عجزوا عن تفسيره
الفيديو تضمنا مشاهده لقطيع من الاغنام
كثيرا في دائره متصله لمده 12 يوما كامله
دون توقف في حركه مستمره في اتجاه عقارب
الساعه داخل حظيرتها لكن العلماء كشفت ان
الاغنام قد تكون بقيت في داخل الحظيره
لفترات طويله وهذا قد يؤدي الى سلوكا نمطي
مع الدوران المتكرر بسبب الاحباط من
الوجود في مساحه محدوده
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو ارتاحت ومقاطع فيديو ارتاحت
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الاحتجاجات
العالميه في المصنع الرئيسي لهواتف ايفون
الذي يضم نحو مئتي الف عامل بعد ان تم
احتجازهم
من قبل السلطات لاكثر من شهر بسبب قيود
كورونا وسيا وسياسه صفر كوبل
[موسيقى]
يعني هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء